yeah welcome to this video I'm playing
Thunder shot from Brazil damn dude for a
London system set up a very odd leak
will be six but we will see one should
be okay to prepare c4 cover be too hmm
maybe you can take on p1 or so just
considering this all right but let's
just develop here
the question is should i play h3 at some
point I always like to have this in and
now let's gain some space with before
the whole queen bee 6r maneuver didn't
really help them much black eyes of
course fairly solid he is not in trouble
I have an easy planned I'll be 50 this
is normally really bad because of the
ship is 6ish up a six b7 winning in
exchange answer quite difficult to
prevent
no he doesn't try and maybe e5 him yeah
I can play that anyway on e5 I will just
drop back I won't take well it's not
there's no big reason why not take to be
honest if you play see 5
yeah but why take if he if he takes on
d4 I just recaptured and it's it's just
easy or maybe a white word wait maybe
night takes if I take with the nighttime
threatening knight c6 which is quite a
threat winning the Queen
if it takes on d4 this is a very nice
position and it doesn't have any kind of
counter play mmmm i only hope i do i'm
not making this too complicated
sometimes you want to play the precise
moves and just plain nonsense for
instance knight c6 maybe isn't a threat
because of Knight c3 hmm yes
hmm f5 is also hanging
ok let's take here first I take on f6
with check check and take the exchange
next yeah it's still good it's still
good I am I really I didn't didn't
calculate this properly but it's still
good for one
Quincy 6mm or just take it yet yeah it's
not not so easy maybe Quincy six it's
good yeah let's take it everyone and now
just take here if he takes on d4 takes
c6 and this is crumbling but what do you
want coming the rookies hanging
you have Brooke the eight or something I
just play probably what you want
young Luke c8 is playing for weeks ahead
hmm yeah I should just play pee play
cook i am it's just the new exchange
and I don't shouldn't make it too
complicated I was calculating stuff like
a 5 rook c8 a takes b6 completely
unnecessary I just need to keep this
exchange and get my room set to play the
rooks are not doing much at the moment I
look on d1 record see one and push the
pawns should be a relatively easy
victory came I'd like to get this tempo
of course
you should to h3 yeah why not here after
captures and threatening a five and
maybe the default is actually dangerous
hmm maybe you should have exchanged not
quite sure
I can clear take and play d4 I think I'm
playing this a bit but turn and precise
but now there's lots of stuff hanging I
can take this it's made only eight black
resins you have to be six bishop asics
it's probably just lost them being you
doin Big material oh it's not lost
curious I can take on c5 the good movie
is be five okay yeah b5 is interesting
but what what I overlooked her this is
interesting here look now this is bad
but he can take here and whatever i
doing now yeah we should where they
played this far too quickly look here
and then it can can just take like this
yeah well I'm not sure if I would have
seen that even with more time on the
clock but he's got definite play here
and also can also take here probably
yeah okay this isn't it brilliant from
black the other line is really good and
this I cannot do we call of Queen 85
takes pawn takes and I've got two pieces
I so I completely misjudged that a third
Bishop a six would be excellent i played
this also very quickly be five though as
a strong and if you look at this a bit
more you you can so you can see why
takes a silencer by z 6 and this is
very strong porn and if he keeps the
tension there's and the capture this
kind of line is very very good for white
still the sea porn now not interesting
thanks for watching